bonjour Tanny Mohamed Soignies merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes élu de Mayotte membre du groupe
RDPI ce sont les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle on va bien sûr
longuement parler de la situation à
Mayotte dans quelques instants mais
d'abord évidemment l'actualité c'est la
réforme des retraites et on le voit
nouvelle journée de mobilisation demain
à l'appel de l'ensemble des syndicats
toujours unis le gouvernement n'a-t-il
pas tort de rester sourd à cette
mobilisation des Français la réforme des
retraites faisait partie du programme du
candidat Emmanuel Macron
c'est tout à fait normal qu'un candidat
élu décline ça
son programme
ce qui se passe dans la rue et
compréhensible les gens ont peur pour
leur avenir pour le retraite il y a un
travail parlementaire qui a commencé et
je pense que dans un pays de droit comme
le nôtre il faut également faire
confiance au parlementaire les lignes
ont bougé il y a des concessions de la
part de la part du gouvernement et moi
je suis dessus qui naturellement font
confiance aussi aux travaux
parlementaires qui vont permettre
d'aboutir à un accord en tout cas à un
vote équilibré
ces travaux parlementaires ils
n'avancent pas on a encore dans
l'article 1 les débats sont longs à
l'Assemblée en plus ils se déroulent
dans un temps contraint puisque vendredi
prochain à minuit ça devrait être
terminé vous pensez vraiment qu'on peut
miser sur le travail parlementaire quand
il se fait dans de telles conditions
dans mes propos j'ai anticipé sur ce qui
va se passer au
les débats je l'espère et j'ai confiance
là-dessus vont se dérouler d'une autre
manière
vous pensez de façon plus constructive
je l'espère en tout cas parce que c'est
important aussi que les Français sur les
points importants tout est important
mais sur les points les plus importants
en temps de ce que leur représentant on
va dire vous dites le gouvernement a
déjà changé le texte c'est vrai que la
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron s'était 65 là
on est à 64 mais quand même vous
entendez les inquiétudes des Français il
y a pas d'autres améliorations à amener
à cette réforme
le programme d'Emmanuel Macron était axé
sur ces 65 ans
la première ministre
a fait une concession pour passer à 64
ans tout a été revu sur la pénibilité
sur les pensions les les plus faibles
des Français chacun a son opinion et
justement c'est dans le cadre d'un débat
parlementaire que l'on pourra accorder
nos violons si je puis dire puisqu'on va
évidemment parler de Mayotte dans
quelques secondes la réforme des
retraites elles ne s'appliquera pas à
Mayotte la réforme des retraites telles
que les prévues dans le droit commun ne
s'appliquera pas Mayotte parce que
Mayotte nous avons commencé à cotiser
les premiers cotisants ont commencé qu'à
partir de 1987 et puisque vous le savez
c'est un système basé sur la la
cotisation le nombre le nombre d'années
normal que la réforme ne s'applique pas
en tant que tel mais bien évidemment
nous allons profiter de ce texte pour
demander que la convergence des droits
sociaux à Mayotte s'accélère et que les
retraites faméliques que touchent
aujourd'hui ne retraités la moyenne et
aux alentours de
20087 euros
[Musique]
de cotisations et aujourd'hui un moyen
de 287 euros
elle doit être complétée nous allons
nous demandons que elle soit réévaluée
parce que on ne peut pas vivre avec une
somme comme celle comme celle-là dans un
territoire où en plus il y a une fierté
de la vie qui peut atteindre jusqu'à 30
35% des prix c'est pour ça que nous
mettons à profit ce texte pour demander
au gouvernement de de faire un geste à
l'égard des des retraités mahoriens
parce que si le retraités n'ont pas
cotisé ce n'est pas parce qu'il ne le
voulait pas mais parce que le système
les pouvoirs publics n'avaient pas mis
en place un système de cotisations
Mayotte Mayotte au bord de l'explosion
c'est le titre du reportage de notre
journaliste Jérôme Rabier diffusé demain
sur notre antenne à 18h il est tourné il
y a quelques semaines dans votre
département qui connaît une situation
difficile il nous rejoint pour en parler
[Musique]
bonjour Jérôme bonjour Oriane bonjour
monsieur sénateur et Jérôme c'est donc
vous qui avez réalisé sur portage
diffusé deux mains sur notre antenne
pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous
pencher sur la situation Mayotte
département français seulement depuis
2011 un département français mais qui
concentre beaucoup de difficultés
immigration pauvreté insécurité et il a
été mis sur le devant de la scène en
particulier à l'automne dernier pas pour
des bonnes raisons et pour la violence
qui ravage l'île et en novembre dernier
il y a eu une attaque un peu plus
violente que les autres qui a touché un
bus scolaire sur la route de l'école des
enfants ont été attaqués je vous propose
de regarder ce premier extrait qui
montre bien l'ampleur du problème
Mayotte novembre 2022
sur la route de l'école un bus est
attaqué par des jeunes cagoulés
armés de machettes il force l'entrée du
bus avant d'y pénétrer
[Musique]
un assaut d'une rare violence pour voler
quelques téléphones bilan de l'attaque
cinq jeunes blessés par des coups de
machette et des éclats de vitres
quelques semaines après l'attaque du bus
l'heure est au bilan pour la société
Matisse qui gère la moitié du transport
scolaire de Lille
[Musique]
alors ça c'est notre buste du 16
novembre dernier qui s'est fait
totalement pulvériser par une attaque de
nigelle des vitres cassées à coups de
pierre à coups de couteau qu'on appelle
le chombo ici donc aucune vitre de la
tenue j'ai perdu 80% du vitrage de ce
véhicule mais c'est malheureusement que
l'un de ceux qui se font agresser chaque
jour chaque semaine et chaque mois de
s'écoulent depuis plus de deux ans la
société Mathis qui gère la moitié du
transport scolaire de Lille notamment la
zone Nord qui concentre le plus de
difficultés à la constaté une explosion
indés agressions sur les bus scolaires
il y a pas un jour où il y a pas un de
leur bus qui est caillassé ou attaqué
façon plus violente les délinquants se
sont des jeunes mineurs isolés étrangers
en grande partie
issue des Comores ils sont plusieurs
milliers à vivre dans les bidonvilles
qui pullulent sur l'île ils sont arrivés
des Comores ou alors ils sont nés à
Mayotte deux parents eux-mêmes
clandestins car c'est problématique
principale de l'île c'est l'immigration
et plus particulièrement celle en
provenance des Comores une immigration
de masque puis de masse pardon puisque
dans ce département qui officiellement
compte 300 000 habitants il y a 50 % de
la population qui est étrangère pour
venir à Mayotte territoire français il
quitte l'île Dom Juan qui situe à 60 km
il tente une périlleuse traversée sur
des bateaux très précaires les quoi ça
quoi ça et ils arrivent sur les plages
de Mayotte notamment à l'ouest et au sud
et on est allé avec vous monsieur le
sénateur tanimohamed Soignies à la
rencontre du maire de boisny-boigny
c'est une commune du sud ou très
régulièrement des bateaux de migrants
débarquent je vous propose de regarder
cet extrait
en fait les bateaux arrivent du nord de
l'entraîneur
mais puisque là-bas il fut un temps il y
avait énormément de contrôle tout le
monde savait que qu'ils arrivaient là
les ils ont décidé de descendre un peu
au sud et donc il descendent ici et très
régulièrement là j'arrive à 50 mètres
vraiment ils sont dans les cailloux là
et puis il viennent ici et il remonte
ici pour s'abriter dans les hauteurs
l'immigration a fait exploser la
démographie de Lille la population a
doublé de 150 000 à 300 000 habitants
sans compter tous les migrants illégaux
il y a plus de 50% de la population à
Mayotte qui est en situation irrégulière
partout au monde on connaît pas ça on
disait tout à l'heure il y a des études
qui disent qu'en Mayotte il y a à peu
près 700 000 habitants officiellement on
est à 300 000 là récemment lycée la
collection que l'ici a fait 300000 c'est
pas vivable pendant des années on a
parlé d'une bombe à retardement et bien
là la bombe A péter en fait la bombe a
pété et la déflagration et là il faut
faire en sorte que c'est déflagration
soit la moins pire possible monsieur le
sénateur on va revenir sur ces deux
extraits et d'abord le premier est très
fort c'est le début du reportage de
Jérôme comment vous expliquer ces
phénomènes de violence
ce sont d'abord merci de consacrer cette
matinée à
Mayotte ces phénomènes comme je viens de
le dire dans ce reportage sur
l'accumulation
d'année d'inaction ou d'action
insuffisante
moi je me suis toujours souvenu avant
même d'être en politique de responsable
politique de l'époque qui disait nous
avons à faire à une bombe à retardement
et c'est vrai que
les bidonvilles n'ont pas
ne sont pas arrivés à maillot du jour au
lendemain ce sont des bidonvilles qu'on
a vu
s'accumuler d'année en année
je me souviens j'étais ici à métropole
pendant mes études dans les années 90 et
déjà on m'appelait on me disait mais
chaque année nous voyons chaque jour
nous voyons arriver des quoi ça de quoi
ça quoi ça des dizaines des dizaines de
personnes
et donc c'est une situation qui a été je
vais dire entretenu par l'inaction
pendant des années et aujourd'hui on
arrive à la à la situation actuelle que
que tout le monde que tout le monde
connaît
vous l'avez dit il y a un problème
d'immigration
il y a un problème de non encadrement de
non occupations
d'enfants qui à partir des années 90
vous voyez leurs parents expulsés vers
les Comores mais ces enfants sont restés
sur place et ont grandi sans encadrement
avec comme seule référence la loi de la
jungle et même ceux qui sont nés sur
place et dont les parents sont en
situation été en situation irrégulière
et bien ils ont grandi avec
sans règles en fait de d'éducation comme
un enfant devrait devrait en avoir voilà
résumé
c'est beaucoup plus pour vous du coup et
pour les habitants sur place il y a
clairement le lien à faire entre la
délinquance que connaît votre
département et l'immigration massive
avec tout ce que je viens de vous dire
avec toute la démonstration qui vient
d'être faite nous ne ils ont pas ce lien
pour nous amuser pour faire plaisir à
certains extrémistes mais là le lien est
évident puisque déjà la pénétration dans
dans le territoire Mahoré se fait
massivement de façon illégale et puis
des enfants qui sont de moins en moins
jeunes qui vivent dans la précarité et
vous mettez n'importe quel être humain
dans ces conditions et bien on aboutit
au cocktail final sur plusieurs milliers
c'est des mineurs isolés étrangers un
peu livré vous l'avez dit à la loi de la
jungle qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
encadrer 3000 5000 mineurs comme ça qui
sème le chaos sur l'île
c'est difficile de rattraper quelque
chose qui aurait dû être fait et qui qui
ne l'a pas été
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer lors de son récent passage le
premier passage à Mayotte avec le
ministre délégué aux outre-mer on
parlait d'un encadrement par les
militaires en s'inspirant de ce qui se
fait d'ores et déjà avec le système
militaire adapté nous attendons la
déclinaison la précision de ce genre
d'encadrement mais lorsque je dis cela
je parle des mineurs
qui sont
un voie de socialisation qui peuvent
être socialisées ou associés il va de
soi que pour les criminels que pour les
délinquants c'est la voie judiciaire qui
doit être leur être réservé aujourd'hui
il manque un centre éducatif fermé nous
avons poussé j'ai été l'un de ceux qui
ont poussé pour que ce centre soit mis
en place le garde des sceaux le premier
pour
2024 ça fait partie ça ne va pas ce
n'est pas la solution magique mais ça
fait partie
de la batterie de solutions qu'il faudra
appliquer pour
espérer résoudre ce fléau vous avez des
chiffres assez parlants sur l'explosion
du nombre de naissances là-bas est-ce
que ce que ça représente oui pour se
rendre compte la maternité de Mamoudzou
la grande ville de Mayotte
c'est 10000 plus de 10000 naissances par
an il y a pas une maternité en France ni
même en Europe qui a autant de naissance
pourtant il y a que 300 000 habitants
plus de 10000 naissances par an et les
trois plus les trois quarts sont issus
deux parents étrangers et donc on le
voit bien cette c'est une classe par
jour qui n'est à la maternité de
Mamoudzou et donc le défi qui pèse sur
tous les services publics ensuite pour
organiser la vie sur le territoire tout
ça ça met une pression intense ça va de
la circulation à l'école aux soins bref
ça pèse sur l'ensemble des services
publics du territoire
pour la population pour la population
c'est intenable ça fait depuis des
années que tout le monde crie au secours
la situation a dépassé tout le monde
tout le monde sur place et il est plus
qu'urgent que des mesures soient prises
pour indiquer ce problème mais réponse
on va peut-être le voir d'abord avec un
nouvel extrait Jérôme et puis après on
verra quelle réponse on peut apporter à
ça une des réponses l'État mais le
paquet sur le sécurité et en priorité le
migratoire il suffit de se déplacer sur
l'île pour rencontrer énormément de
force de police qui patrouille qui font
des checkpoints pour contrôler la
population ils arrêtent principalement
des clandestins Comoriens et quand ils
sont arrêtés ils sont emmenés au cras le
centre de rétention administrative de
Mayotte et dans ce centre l'activité
elle est plus qu'intense j'ai pu
constater ça avec mon caméraman Clément
de Besse c'est simple là-bas on voit
passer davantage de clandestins que dans
l'ensemble des centres de rétention de
France et donc je vous propose de
regarder cet extrait
on a une moyenne à peu près de 82 si on
lit sur l'année à peu près 82 personnes
intégrées chaque jour au centre de
rétention le centre de rétention
accueille en moyenne plus de 30 000
aussi par an sur la moyenne de
l'ensemble des CRA de France globalement
sur l'année 2021 on a accueilli nous
avons accueilli 63% de l'ensemble des
rétentions en France
ce matin là ce sont encore près de 80
comoriens qui sont expulsés du
territoire depuis le centre de rétention
direction le port
l'accompagnement des policiers français
s'arrête ici sur le quai
[Musique]
c'est un bateau commercial sur lequel on
embarque les retenues et qui seront qui
seront renvoyés aux Comores sur un même
sur un même bateau qu'avec des passagers
en fait commerciaux on fait des
loinement en métropole par bateau ou par
avion mais on met jamais sans ou 150
personnes éloignées en même temps sur un
bateau quoi non et qu'ici qu'on voit ça
tout à fait
[Musique]
ces images que vous voyez d'expulsion
c'est tous les jours à Mayotte une un
bateau qui part pour expulser vers les
Comores 80 100 personnes parfois encore
davantage en fonction du nombre de
bateaux interceptés la nuit de gens qui
essayent de rentrer sur le territoire de
Mayotte c'est énorme alors la réponse de
l'État elle est très ferme elle est très
forte 20 000 en 2021 25 000 expulsions
en 2022 donc bien davantage que pour
toute la France pour l'Hexagone c'est
15000 expulsions dans l'année rien que
Mayotte c'est 25000 expulsions dans
l'année faut bien se rendre compte mais
cette réponse de l'État elle a aussi ses
limites les associations et dénonce un
respect des droits qui est plus que
limite sur le territoire de Mayotte
puisque ils sont arrêtés ils sont
expulsés en moins de 24 heures donc il
est pas toujours évident de vérifier la
situation des personnes qui sont
expulsées certaines ont fait des
démarches auraient le droit de rester
sur le territoire mais parfois on n'a
pas le temps de prouver qu'elles ont
fait ces démarches elles sont tout de
même et expulsés et au total il faut
bien se rendre compte que c'est près de
10% de la population officielle de l'île
qui a expulsé chaque année c'est énorme
la réponse de l'État est la bonne pour
vous animerait
d'insister sur ces efforts qui ont été
faits parce que
il n'y a de pire il n'y a rien de pire
d'un territoire que que la démagogie
d'entendre certains dire que rien n'est
fait
le les forces de l'ordre ont été
doublées ont été doublés mais le compte
n'y est pas si je puis dire parce que
nous n'arrivons pas à endiguer le
problème mais il ne faut pas dire que
rien n'a été fait parce que si le même
effort a été soutenu pendant toutes ces
années on n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui
mais il faut reconnaître cet effort qui
a qui a de doublement des forces de l'or
actuellement à notre demande le raid et
reste de de façon de façon pérenne
euh pour continuer dans dans cette voie
il faut améliorer le renseignement parce
que les réseaux il y a des réseaux de
personnes en situation
irrégulière s'organise de plus en plus
s'organise de mieux en mieux et c'est
l'étape au niveau des forces de l'ordre
à franchir mais évidemment pour répondre
à votre question ce n'est pas suffisant
si c'était suffisant on en serait pas là
on a on a pas de réparer je tenais à
préciser ses efforts sans conséquence
qui va arriver au Sénat dans quelques
semaines maintenant est-ce que pour vous
il faut des mesures spécifiques pour
Mayotte est-ce qu'il faut restreindre
encore plus le droit du sol qui est déjà
différent à Mayotte que sur le reste du
territoire oui à mon initiative le les
conditions d'acquisition de la
nationalité ont été modifiées en 2018
le projet de loi tel que il a été
présenté aujourd'hui au Sénat ne
contient pas de mesures spécifiques à
Mayotte sur ce sujet ou sur un autre
sujet moi je suis de ceux qui
disons effectivement renforçant le
dispositif mais faisons-le avec
l'existant déjà lorsque j'ai défendu les
dispositions
dérogatoires actuelles devant le Conseil
d'État en 2018 le Conseil d'État a
précisé quels étaient
équilibrées et adaptés proportionnée
adapté et le Conseil d'État avait ajouté
deux conditions supplémentaires et force
de constater que ces conditions ne sont
pas à ce jour respecter la première
condition c'était laquelle c'était de
mener une campagne de dissuasion à
l'endroit des comoriennes candidates
pour venir mettre au monde des enfants à
Mayotte
ces femmes croient à une chimère d'un
droit du sol automatique comme ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis or ce n'est pas le
cas le droit du sol en France n'est pas
automatique et avec ces dispositions
nous avons ajouté une condition
supplémentaire mais lorsque une femme
qui veut profiter des dispositions sur
le droit du sol au départ des Comores ne
sait pas que sur place ça ne marchera
pas mais elle va quand même continuer à
y aller cette campagne de dissuasion
alors que nous aurions pu le faire et il
aurait pu se mettre en place à la radio
comme comme ça se fait la radio à
Mayotte
elle aurait dû être faite de façon
intensive la deuxième condition qui
avait été émise par le Conseil d'État
qui n'est pas respecté c'est une lutte
farouche contre les reconnaissances de
complaisance parce que le délai
de trois mois aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
bénéficier du droit du sol pour son
enfant on peut l'augmenter à un an à 10
ans mais si il faut pour vous parce que
il est venu il a proposé de l'augmenter
c'est la bonne solution mais si par par
une reconnaissance frauduleuse un
Français qui reconnaît un enfant qui ne
peut pas bénéficier du droit du sol à
Mayotte et bien par cette reconnaissance
on peut mettre tout ça à plat et bien ça
ne sert à rien de de durcir le
dispositif tant qu'on n'a pas amélioré
ce dispositif tant qu'on connaît pas
aller au bout de l'existant donc moi je
a priori je ne suis pas opposé à ce que
on aille plus loin mais
pas dans l'immédiat en tout cas il
aurait fallu pour cela
un rapport pour dire depuis que ces
dispositions se délai de un an il reste
l'être humain
pour dire où est-ce qu'on en est ces
dispositions qui touchent quand même
plus de la moitié de naissance c'est
énorme ces dispositions qui touchent
plus de la moitié de naissance et bien
une étude d'impact aurait été nécessaire
pour savoir où on en est et pour voir
éventuellement comment aller plus loin
dernière question Mayotte est devenue
département il y a un petit peu plus de
10 ans est-ce que pour vous ça a été un
échec cette départementalisation pas du
tout pas du tout
il y a une confusion souvent des choses
lorsqu'on dit que la
départementalisation de Mayotte est un
échec la départementalisation de Mayotte
et la suite logique de l'entrée de
Mayotte au sein de la France en 1841
c'est une aspiration de toutes les
générations qui a fini par se
concrétiser maintenant dans les
modalités de mise en oeuvre de la
départementalisation mais c'est facile
de tirer des conclusions à la fin on
aurait pu on aurait dû s'y prendre
autrement et mieux préparer le le
territoire à la départementalisation
aujourd'hui ce qui ne va pas ce n'est
pas la départementalisation mais c'est
la distorsion
des niveaux de vie entre notre voisinage
y compris Madagascar y compris l'Afrique
et nous mais les maorilles qui sont des
Français et des Européens ne vont pas
retarder et cesser leur développement
parce que les autres pays aux alentours
le censurent pas comme il faudrait merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous et
merci Jérôme votre reportage Mayotte au
bord de l'explosion et donc avoir sur
notre antenne demain à 18h merci à tous
les deux dans le club des territoires
dans 20 minutes on va parler de la
réforme des retraites l'examen reprend
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée alors que une
journée une quatrième journée de
mobilisation est annoncée pour demain et
on va en parler tout de suite avec notre
prochaine invité c'est Jean-Claude Mahy
qui nous rejoint